What do you think?
>> I think it's hill climbing.
>> Me, too.
>> It's certainly not simulated annealing because there's no annealing.
>> Yup.
>> Simulated or otherwise. You might think
it's genetic algorithms because you've got all
of these centers that are all moving around at once, but they're all a
part of the ultimate answer. They're not
populations. So it's really hill climbing. You
just take a step towards a configuration
that's better than the configuration you had before.
>> That's right, except what we haven't said yet is the
way we defined hill climbing, it actually evaluated the score and
chose a neighbor that maximized the score. And we didn't show
that these steps actually do that. We just defined them in
a particular way. Here's the wicked cool thing. It really does
do hill climbing. It really does find the neighbor that maximizes
the score, minimizes the error in this case. So let's show
that because it's kind of neat. Every time I see this
I'm always surprised and delighted.
>> Oh, I'm looking forward to being delighted.